ضمن محاولات تبرير قصف واستهداف
المستشفيات في غزه عرض الجيش الاسرائيلي
صورا لمستشفى حمد الدولي للتاهيل والاطراف
الصناعيه المعروف بالمستشفى القطري زاعما
وجود انفاق تابعه لحماس اسفل المستشفى
وعرض صوره لما قال انها فتحه النفق
المزعوم تحقيق للجزيره كشف ان تلك وها ما
هي الا مدخل غرفه تستخدم لتخزين المياه
بالجانب الشرقي للمستشفى وبعوده الى مقطع
قديم سجل قبل ثمان سنوات للاعمال
الانشائيه للمستشفى تبين ان هذه الغرفه
مسجله ضمن المخطط الرسمي للمنشاه كما تبين
ان استخدام مثل هذه الخزانات شائع في
مستشفيات اخرى بعضها في الولايات المتحده
في الجهه الشرقيه من المستشفى الشيخ حمد
هناك خزان خرساني تحت الارض يطل منه فوق
سطح الارض فوهه خرسانيه وغطاء معدني
وانبوب للتهويه الذي يستخدم لاخراج وتصريف
الهواء بعد دخول المياه الى الخزان يستخدم
لتجميع المياه والاحتفاظ بها لري المساحات
الخضراء في ساحه المستشفى يستخدم ايضا
لتزويد المستشفى في المياه في حاله
انقطاعها من الخزانات العلويه في المقابل
دعت حركه حماس الامم المتحده والمنظمات
الدوليه ياره مستشفيات القطاع المحاصر
للوقوف على حقيقه المزاعم
الاسرائيليه بحسب وزاره الصحه ف ان جيش
الاحتلال تسبب في اخراج 16 مستشفى و32
مركزا صحيا عن الخدمه عبر قطع الوقود او
القصف الذي استهدف
116 مؤسسه صحيه منذ بدايه العدوان على غزه
في السابع من اكتوبر ابرز استهدافات
الاحتلال للمنشات الطبيه نتجت عنها زره
المستشفى المعمداني التي راح ضحيتها مئات
الشهداء
[موسيقى]
والجرحى